[Music]
all right now the democrats divisive
partisan
unconstitutional post-presidency
impeachment trial charade is getting a
heavy dose of reality tonight it's done
it's over
as earlier today professor jonathan
turley democrat met with the republican
senators discussing the trial
and of course 45 gop senators voted
against moving forward
with the salvia sham meanwhile senator
ted cruz is leading a group of
republicans who are proposing a two-term
limit for senators and three-term limit
for house members
as by the way that comes as senator cruz
was attacked by actor seth rogen
who's he kidding on twitter and
repeatedly calling him a fascist and
numerous
profanity-laced tweets as if anyone
gives a rip
senator ted cruz joins us now for
reaction
uh senator who cares badge of honor
congratulations
um i got to give you a lot of credit now
it's amazing
that all you and josh hawley were asking
was for an
audit the guy that carried the
impeachment papers leading the effort
challenged the 2016 election did they
not realize their pure hypocrisy on
display here
senator well sean it's great to be with
you this evening
you were right that the democrats are
demonstrating a lot of hypocrisy
right now they're demonstrating anger
and rage you know last week i was
sitting
out on out of the back of the capitol
and i listened to joe biden give his
inauguration speech and i
actually thought it was a good speech i
was glad to hear him make a call for
unity to say the country should come
together
but unfortunately congressional
democrats apparently weren't listening
to a word he said
because the very first step they took
after hearing an impassioned plea for
unity
is to charge down the road of a partisan
divisive
angry impeachment trial and this is not
driven by the needs of the country this
is not driven by trying to help out
the people who are hurting back home
this is driven really by
the partisan rage and the partisan anger
the democrats feel
they hate donald j trump and and they're
engaging in
an act that i think is petty i think it
is retribution
i think it is vindictive and i think
it's a waste of time and
and so to coin a phrase i think it's
time to move on
it's time to move on and focus on
helping people get back to work
helping people beat this global pandemic
bringing america back to where we
should be not these partisan games the
democrats are playing
all right impeachment is over because no
way 45 senators that say it's
unconstitutional could turn around and
say oh okay
but there's important principles in play
here
why would people legitimize validate the
house's
snap impeachment one number two if we're
gonna
we're not gonna if we're now going to
use
that standard let's apply it to schumer
kamala harris joe biden maxine waters
and nancy pelosi let's start there
thirdly there is something that's called
the constitution
never mind there was no due process no
investigation no defense
no opportunity now we're learning that a
lot of this apparently
according to court documents washington
post fake news cnn
was pre-planned senator well don't we
need the equivalent of a 9 11
report to make sure this never happens
again ever ever
ever well let me take those one at a
time
you were right that what the house did
in this so-called impeachment
doesn't meet the constitutional standard
they didn't pretend to follow due
process
they didn't have hearings they didn't
pretend to look at any facts or any
evidence
this was an exercise of political rage
it was their id speaking they hate
donald trump for anyone who hadn't been
paying attention
they've made it very very clear and look
these are the same democrats who four
years ago in 2017 17 actually
in december of 2016 before trump was
sworn in
said they wanted to impeach him they've
wanted to impeach him from the beginning
they did it a year ago
i feel like i'm kind of trapped in
groundhog day where apparently
every january we're going to be doing
another impeachment so i guess next year
i don't know maybe it'll be the
impeachment of jimmy carter or the
impeachment of bill clinton or the
impeachment of barack obama because
that's what we do in januaries
but this was not driven by facts it was
not driven by the evidence it was driven
instead
by extreme partisanship and i don't
think that's what the american people
want anyone who looks at
the november election it was not a
mandate
for the left to go crazy hard and
extreme
and and the problem sean right now the
people driving the train in the joe
biden administration
and the chuck schumer and nancy pelosi
congress
are the extreme left the first week in
office what has joe biden done
he signed an executive order ending the
keystone pipeline
destroying 11 000 jobs eight thousand
union jobs
with a stroke of a pen he said your jobs
don't matter what else have they done
i'll tell you this first week it has
been quite dismaying seeing biden
nominee after biden nominee
get cozy with china explain how i've
asked multiple nominees will you commit
to maintaining the entities list that
sanctions
companies in china that are using their
technology to repress
and oppress one million uyghurs to
commit horrific human rights violations
and and not a single one of those biden
nominees
will make that commitment i think they
are preparing to get in bed with china
and and that's an extreme agenda that's
not what the american people want
senator we got by you know you know with
the stroke of a pen
an executive fiat we got let's see we're
back in the climate paris climate
agreement where
oh china is a developing nation we're
not
uh then of course we got uh
you know the end of the keystone uh xl
pipeline now the wall
building is gonna stop uh entire
industries wiped out with that stroke of
a pen
senator entire industries interviewed a
guy last night
got into more detail on radio today he's
got three kids
uh they're making over a hundred grand a
year
uh where is he going to replace that job
with
11 million plus uh uh americans getting
amnesty
during the middle of a pandemic how is
he going to replace that hundred
thousand dollar a year job
sean you're exactly right what the
democrats are making clear is that
today's democratic party
is the party of hollywood celebrities
it's it's the party of big tech
billionaires it's the party of
the incredibly wealthy coastal elites
but if you're actually a working person
in this country if you're a union member
if you're blue
collar if you've got calluses on your
hands if you're a cop
or a firefighter or a waiter or waitress
or construction worker
this democratic party doesn't care about
you and there's an irony i mean i mean
it wasn't too long ago you and i are
both old enough
to remember when the democratic party
was the party of fdr where union members
considered
considered fdr our president
but today's democratic party has said
they don't
care about your jobs and in fact the
defense of the extreme left let's take
keystone pipeline
11 000 jobs eliminated 8 000 union jobs
here's what the left says and the media
says
well those were just temporary jobs so
they don't matter
those were construction jobs and
construction jobs matter
and we ought to be fighting for jobs in
this country we ought to be defending
the ability of families to provide for
themselves you know
i've always said term limits a bad idea
as time has come
i think i agree with you but i think
it's a bad idea
whose time has come all right senator
thank you good to see you
when we